oh yes as you saw a trailer for Dark
Tower came out and I did a video about
it because it looked intriguing and
interesting and I wanted to talk about
that in the comment section of that
trailer video taught me a valuable
lesson which is no one gives a [ __ ]
about a Dark Tower trailer with a
defender's trailer drop that same day
dark towers [ __ ] cool plus I really
tried on a Matthew McConaughey
impersonation in that video so everyone
check it out or go check it out so
here's me talking about the defenders
trailer which is a trailer for a show
that I know about 50% of the crew the
defenders are comprised of daredevil
Jessica Jones Luke Cage and iron fist
I've seen two of those shows Luke Cage
and iron fist know Luke Cage because
it's just I'm busy as [ __ ] I'm adulting
in my world while trying to maintain my
man-child world of my youtube channel
and exists because everyone i know it's
like a sec you don't need to watch it
it's boring as [ __ ] i haven't watched it
as right even the reviewer listens to
people he knows when it comes to wasting
or not wasting ten hours of television
so the defenders trailer starts out
jessica jones is in this interrogation
room that she's pretty much she's in the
[ __ ] she's getting grilled the door
busts open her lawyer comes in he's like
don't say another word yet her lawyer is
Matt Murdock I was like alright it's
pretty sweet I do like when Luke Cage
and iron fist mean they're like whoa who
are you who are you iron fist first of
all three ninjas and [ __ ] with the
pressure point so doesn't do anything in
Luke ages like gods knocks him down iron
fist has the glowing fist and then
cracks Luke Cage which is a throwback to
the season Luke Cage when the knuckle
just shatters on Luke cages face yeah I
thought that but I've seen a couple
episodes of Luke Asian didn't get to
finish it iron fist is like that's right
that's what happens but no one likes
your show you get fuel then you hear
this voiceover took me a second I was
like ooh that stick from daredevil it
sticks still trying to get his army
together holy crap you do see Elektra
maybe she's coming back right when six
says the war for New York is here it's
not a battleground state but it's
important Sigourney said I have no idea
who's the gurney Weaver plays I'm sure a
lot of people out there do but I just I
keep my head out of the rumor mill I'm
like I like being surprised when I watch
movies and TV shows I don't want to know
who Sigourney Weaver plays that said
it's in the comments section now so that
was kind of kind of productive binstock
says get your [ __ ] together and there's
pretty much a montage of fighters that
hallway fight was pretty good okay come
on
Bam Bam Bam some about seeing
individuals that you've seen in
individual forms entertain
that have now come together another
fighting together it's like that first
time you ever saw the Avengers stand up
in that Super Bowl trailer for The
Avengers that's kind of what the hallway
by fly give us the good trailer is
pretty much the Avengers of this small
screen yeah walk away from this trailer
with a smile on my face I can't say I'm
not looking forward to it looking
forward to it totally curious as to what
you guys thought about it so the
defenders trailer have you seen it what
did you think about it what's your
favorite Marvel Netflix series thus far
whatever it is wherever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]